weed is a tough one sometimes people
just have to run their course with it
and it's safer it's better than other
drugs
you know it's better than somebody doing
a bunch of heroin
cocaine or crack it's better than that
in the sense that it's
you know they're more calmer and that's
nice
but yeah sometimes you want to get them
off it sometimes you can lose a sibling
or a friend
and they get real depthed up into the
weed and they like a damn
swamp it's like talking to they so
planted out
you know all they're doing is just kind
of sitting there like a plant they kind
of become what they smoke
they sit in there and they kind of are
unique but they're really just a [ __ ]
plant
and they want water and that's it man
they just want some water because
they're so high